hello and welcome to itl 4 foundation
tutorial
i am cmr chandra mr a certified itl
experts
and itil managing professional as part
of this tutorial
we are going to understand the framework
itil 4 and also understand the basic
definitions of id service management as
defined in itil best practice
before we get into understanding itr
best practice framework let us
understand the id service management and
its benefit
by applying the best practice framework
itl for what would be the benefits which
we get
so for that let us assume a scenario
where two employees are discussing about
advantages of adopting and adapting itl
best practices
why has itl become so popular these days
large
medium and small organizations across
the world use iti
in order to improve the value of their
services but how can itil improve an
organization's performance
with itil an organization doesn't just
save money but also works
more effectively it also have more
benefits
that are reduced i t cost enhanced i.t
services
improved productivity better management
of business risk and service disruption
improve customer satisfaction by
delivering efficient services and
provides guidance to address service
management challenges
that's great which is the latest itl
framework and
what's new about it itl4 is the latest
update
idl has evolved from many years and it
l4 is the latest version
and this was released in february 2019.
it focuses on practical approach on how
to manage the core principles of quality
services
how to implement itr from large to small
organizations
and how itl can be utilized with
frameworks such as
agile lean and devops now what is in it
for us
to learn and understand from itil4
tutorial so as part of this tutorial
we are going to now look at what is
itil4
elements of the itl4 framework that is
four dimensions
and itl service value chain and its
components
then details about itl for
certifications and
companies using itil so what is itil
itil is set of framework of i.t service
management that helps in aligning i.t
services with the requirements of the
business
so it helps organizations to deliver it
services
using the most efficient method so itil
goal is to improve efficiency and
achieve predictable service delivery
so finally what it means for us when we
say it service management
information technology service
management so itsm
stands for information technology
service management
where it focuses on how an organization
maintains i.t services for customers
also it controls
various activities involved in a process
activities like planning
designing delivering deploying and
managing services
itr four emphasizes the importance of
value creation rather than just
delivering services this involves value
always as lien mentioned repeatedly
value should be always in customer
perspective so there should be an
outcome
generally we use the term called output
for the products or services which are
created
but by using that product or services
one has to have
realization of the value created by it
so that request has certain outcomes
we're not speaking about just the
features and function of a
specific product or services we're
speaking about how the customer is
benefited
from that features and functionality
which helps customer or consumers to
realize the value
then creation of a value should be
always with
collaboration and cooperation so itl4
more emphasizes on co-creation of value
so this also involves managing specific
cost and risk
when we say managing specific cost and
risk it's about
service provider to own the cost and
risk
and this cost and risk is not for the
consumer or customer so value must be
clearly defined as the purpose of an
organization
it is to create value for its
stakeholders whereas
outcome is a result of service they are
specific and
help you know whether you have reached
your goal so now
to understand the outcome of an output
let us understand this example
an output of wedding photography is the
photo album
but the outcome is the satisfaction that
is experienced by the client when
looking at the album
if album is an output in the first case
you can see the
photos are not clear means poor customer
experience that would be the outcome
similarly the album output where it is
very clear
the experience of the customer will be
very good so that is an outcome so
finally
co-creation of value in order to deliver
the high quality output the service
provider should maintain an interactive
relationship with its
stakeholders and customers it's very
essential to interact
understand the prospective view of the
stakeholders and create the value
accordingly
for example co-creation is a business
strategy which helps consumer receives
the results based on the requirements
if you take up this scenario of a
restaurant where service produce
provides certain dish versus service
provider
provides certain facilities to the
consumers of the
food in the restaurant so that they will
have a better experience and feedback
can be provided than in there itself so
this helps the restaurant personnel
to work on those feedbacks and improve
the service experience to the customers
the amount of money spent on specific
activity or resources should be managed
wisely
and as i mentioned earlier cost and risk
of any services
provided by a service provider is with
service provider
consumer of a service just pays for a
service and then
as the service consumption is complete
they will just
off-board themselves like you go and
book a taxi you
get on board to taxi and then you get
off the taxi as you reach your
destination you will not own the vehicle
you are not owning that car you are not
owning that any mobile app if you have
used to book the taxi
all the cost and risk associated with
these service components would be for
service provider another example can be
starbucks has offered internet access to
its customers which means
all the associated components of the
starbucks internet services
the cost and risk associated with that
is owned
by starbucks now what is it il4
so itl 4 how to identify whether a
service is delivering value to customer
and meeting the requirements
solution this can be identified by
evaluating the utility and warranty
now it is very essential to understand
what is utility and warranty for us
so utility refers to the functionality
offered by product
in order to meet a specific requirement
for example utility
of a training service is about the
timings of the service the content
delivered during the services
the profile of the trainer etc whereas
email services if i take an example
utility is all those parameters features
functionalities associated with the
email services like mailbox capacity
or the way the speed of emails sending
or receiving
etc now similarly warranty refers to the
customer with certain assurance of the
products
like service availability information
security
service capacity and service continuity
so these
four service availability information
security or service capacity and service
continuity has to ensure
the specific provided services is having
those solutions which will safeguard
these requirements of the services and
service will become fit for use
if i take a similar example of email
services
which we discussed just now so warranty
is about availability
of email services how save is my message
when i send and receive the messages
means information security capacity do i
have a sufficient capacity so that all
the emails can be stored
and then continuity what happens if
something goes wrong drastically
some failure happens minimum services
should be up and running so that my
messaging services is
on for at least minimum need of the
messaging requirements
that is about warranty so utility refers
to fit for purpose
basically referring to features
functionality of the service
whereas warranty refers to these four
things availability security capacity
and continuity
making a specific services fit for use
so
elements of itl4 so here we are going to
look at
understanding two main elements defined
in itl4
that is four dimensions and itil service
value system
so let us look at four dimensions of
services
so the four dimensions of services
involves organizations and people
information and technology partners and
suppliers
and value streams and processes always
it is required to look at a service
having a holistic picture
so having this holistic picture requires
correct understanding about
these four dimensions of services so
when i say organizations and people when
it's information and technology
partners and suppliers values and value
streams and processes
so all these four dimensions will be
definitely
involved and required to look at for
every services so let us understand
these one by one now
organization people refers to the
organization structure
the culture the people the principles
the values
around revolving around the people and
organization structure which makes
for providing better outcomes for
creating better outcomes for the
services
similarly information and technology
involves information and knowledge which
is
required along with the technology to
provide a required
services and service management the
partners and suppliers focuses on those
stakeholders
who supply certain services for a
service provider so that service
provider can provide the better services
to their consumers of the services
value streams and processes refers to
the series of steps
organization takes to create deliver the
products throughout the service
lifecycle of
services now to take an example if i
assume a services like taxi services
which i defined
earlier we discussed earlier who is
organization and people
the people sitting in the customer care
the people like drivers
the people sitting in the business
people sitting in the finance people
sitting in the technology
so all these forms at an organization
structure having people in it so that
fulfills
organization people dimension of
services whereas information and
technology
like car itself is a technology device
information about the
schedule or information about the driver
similarly the technology platform the
mobile app what you use
can be the one which you can visualize
for information and technology for
partners and suppliers now generally if
you look at
the examples like olar uber services
taxi services
they are not employed by the olar uber
they are the partners and suppliers for
providing the taxi services to ola on
uber on behalf of ola and uber so
similarly internet services
will be provided to all andover by a
supplier so partners and suppliers
involvement is essential in any services
the value streams and processes now when
you actually open a mobile app and book
a taxi
you need a process which has to be
established and defined and this process
would connect to the
trigger or to check what vehicles are
available and book a vehicle for you
allocate a vehicle for the
specific consumer similarly that process
triggering to billing system
likewise many processes are connected
with each other forming a value stream
to achieve a specific objective of a
consumer and this
involves many processes so considering
these four dimensions
every services has these four dimensions
and consideration of these four
dimensions are essential
while strategizing the services
designing the services
transitioning services delivering the
services supporting the services
throughout the life cycle of the
services so all these four dimensions
are impacted by
an external factors six external factors
so these six external factors can also
be called as pastel factors
which is basically political factor
economic factors
social factors technological factors
legal factors
and environmental factors so further
each dimension as i mentioned
is affected by multiple factors and we
saw that and next
let us look at itl service value system
so this forms the
core part of itl framework so this shows
an end-to-end view about what is
involved in service value system so it
starts with opportunity demand which is
shown in the left side
and every services creating the value
and continually
improve to align and create the value so
when i say opportunities and demand
so which becomes a reason for triggering
an actions and activities
and move from left to right similarly as
it moves from left to right
the value is created opportunity the
term opportunity
refers to the needs requirements of
customers or consumers which is realized
by service provider to fulfill
whereas demand represents the
requirement for products and services
from the customers so either opportunity
realized by service provider which is
unfulfilled need of consumers or
customers whereas demand where customer
or consumer is asking and booking those
products or services from you would
create certain actions
with the service providing organizations
so ultimately it should result in
creation of those
products or services with the specific
features and functions so those
would enable the creation of value and
also
that value represents a valuable outcome
now
the components of service value system
as we saw
guiding principles is one of that which
help in providing a comprehensive vision
of
how an organization should manage a
service so there are seven principles
so that is focus on value start where
you are
think and work holistically progress
iteratively with feedback
keep it simple and practical collaborate
and promote visibility
and optimize and automate so when we say
focus on value
which means everything we do as part of
services so every task an organization
does
should create value for stakeholders
especially it should increase to focus
on user experience
and give better consumers experience so
that they can be continually continually
the value is realized by the consumer or
customers
next principle start where you are
refers to ensuring that
organization assess and analyze the
scenarios
to identify and improve things on a
continual basis for example
organization assessing and analyzing the
existing processes to identify and
improve so progress iterative and
feedback
this opts for a feedback during every
iterations of the work
always ensures to organize work into
small and manageable sections which can
lead to quick results
collaborate and promote visibility it is
very essential to collaborate with
customers
users suppliers and all the stakeholders
who are involved in
services and service actions as it helps
in creating
much better value think and work
holistically so this creates
a process that adds value to the
customers or consumers and business
and always helps in identification of
different ways to enhance the
performance of the processes
because this provides the end-to-end
view of services keep it simple and
practical
it is always important to opt for
minimum steps
that are correct and do not add
processes that create
value to the stakeholders optimize and
automate so optimize and automate
refers to consideration of the services
which needs to be optimized and
automated which helps in improving the
efficiency and effectiveness and also
optimize the resources and costs next
component of service value system is
governance so when we say governance
governance basically is responsible for
evaluating directing and monitoring the
i.t service management
by adopting the guiding principles
defined in itl4 framework it may also
does demonstrate these principles
considering
the currently available or the
principles which are defined in the
organization
so this involves three main activities
that is evaluate
direct and monitor so evaluate refers to
the performance
of reviews of the services on a
continual basis
based on the stakeholder requirements so
that how the services are performing
how the new opportunities coming up
would be understood and that can made
visible
the directions whatever is provided
based on the evaluation done
for the itsm organization so that
accordingly the required directions can
be accomplished
when i say direction for example
organization can have directions to
enhance the
business opportunities minus business
opportunities increase the sales by 25
in coming quarter when organization says
this now
in what way it service management can
contribute to that
in what way the readiness of it service
management should be
when organization enhances its business
to 25 percent
should we optimize something with us or
should we increase certain set of
resources and capabilities so that
increase of the business to 25 percent
is actually supported or complemented by
it service management
then as you implement that as this
direction is set whether
itsm is contributing to that has to be
checked monitored
so it has to monitor the performance of
the organization
and has to check whether the practices
the products the services
are there aligned are they aligned are
they in line with the direction given by
the
governing body it is very essential to
understand this
and have this in practice so that
services
always continue to be aligned with the
service
organization's business requirements and
also the organizations or consumers who
are using the services of a service
provider so it aligns to that as well
so evaluate direct and monitor as
happens continually
regularly so that continued alignment of
direction
to the set direction by the governing
body is ensured so next component is
service value chain which is basically a
component which is which is in the
middle of a service value system so this
will have a set of interconnected
activities
that an organization performs to deliver
a valuable product or services
to its consumers so this will have many
activities
like engage plan improve design and
transition
obtain and build a deliverance support
product and services
now as you see in the left side you have
a demand right side you have a value
now the demand which is represented in
the left side you don't see
opportunities as it was mentioned
in the service value system framework in
the left side we had demand and
opportunity in that picture but here
we don't see that the simple reason here
in a service value chain
being part of service value system it is
always demand
when we refer to opportunities in
service value system the moment it is
realized there is a opportunity
the discussion happens based on that and
decision happens as the decisions
happened now it is required to fulfill
that demand by a service providing
organization that is the reason we don't
see the word opportunity here so as the
demand is seen
now the engagement happens now how the
engagement happens
so here it involves first planning
so planning refers to the activities
involving creating plans
portfolios architectures policies etc
which
provides an organization a direction a
clarity
in terms of what to do if you refer to
previous version of it like itl v3
you can think about a service strategy
part of the actions we choose to take
like understanding the perspective of
services planning for the services
understanding service requirements
service level requirements
right so which will enable to get the
clarity in terms of the detail about the
services and what are those results
which are required to be established so
now people would contribute to these
active activities
and must have great analytical and
management skills there should be clear
visualization about the services
end-to-end like the principle we said
having a holistic approach
so unless i have a holistic picture a
bird's-eye view
i cannot understand what services is
being delivered and what is that value
it is going to be created
so this full picture of services
end-to-end has to be visualized that is
the reason plan is on the top like an
umbrella so one has to understand that
very clearly so as you get the insight
towards that particular service
service requirement service level
requirements once the plan is ready
then you will move forward with engage
so
engage with the right set of
stakeholders now why should we engage
with the stakeholders
engaging with stakeholders requires
clear
focus on understanding the requirements
as needed by the consumers
we may require to document this we might
require to understand
what is that people need skills and
competency
right in terms of engaging and we need
to know and demonstrate that so
while you understand and get a good
understanding about the needs of the
stakeholders stakeholders may be like
end user who are using the services
customers who were discussing straight
were given the requirements whereas the
suppliers who is also asking about the
requirements in terms of provisioning
their services to
the service provider so the engagement
should go on with all those stakeholders
to understand clearly and also set the
expectation clearly to those
stakeholders
so you may require to set an expectation
to consumers you may require to set an
expectation suppliers you are required
to set an expectation to users
and this has to continue throughout so
continually engaging
with all the stakeholders throughout the
service value system and it's very
rigorous as part of
service value chain so next activity
would be design and transition
so design and transition focus on
creating and releasing new and change
services now when we say designing a new
services
if you recall the points with what we
had in idle v3
like four ps we used to discuss which we
just saw like four dimensions so people
process
products and partners which is aligned
to four dimensions thought which you
just saw in the previous slides so that
is very essential to visualize
and defining service solution defining
technology architectures
defining processes defining metrics
defining measurement methods and tools
to measure that particular service and
service performance
so this requires understanding and
having those individuals
who have comprehensive understanding
about service management and they should
contribute to this entire exercise of
design and transitioning
so unless you have that holistic picture
what we are mentioning while planning
and also well engaging
to get the clarity so designing would
not provide you that
blueprint required service design
package we call it s which we use this
term in iq3 perspective but however the
terminology would not change
the blueprint the service design package
what you have for a service
it is very necessary to have that in
place with the detailed considerations
of all the four dimensions of the
services and also considering the impact
of the pastel factors
so further obtain and build so obtain
and build focus on development and
management of the infrastructure and
applications
so you obtain means you acquire
resources
you acquire components infrastructure
components like servers
storage database or application
platforms the testing platforms you
acquire
you test those you make it ready you set
up that environment
required for creation of services
transition of a services
you obtain and build then further you
deliver and support this requires to
ensure
that services are delivered and
supported in a way that meets
stakeholders expectations
so as you engage on a continual basis
there is a collaboration which is going
on throughout
and also like progress iteratively with
feedback you need to take that approach
so that you will have a feedback so by
doing this
you are demonstrating all the seven
principles right
so services provisioning is one part of
it new services provisioning or
modifying the existing services
to enhance the performance of the
existing services with added features
and functionality
is one thought similarly while there is
an incident
while there is a disruption while there
is a failure it is required to
resolve those even in that scenario one
has to understand
what are the impacts to the services
what are the impacts to the business
and handle accordingly and this is true
for
while introducing new services and while
resolving the
incidents or issues associated with the
specific
services which are up and running so
when
it is happening with the better
collaboration with the customers
consumer suppliers
every stakeholders obviously will
involve actively
and they contribute as well as realize
the value
it is very important that people
contributing to this activity
and need to be very good at prioritizing
and managing complex workloads
so services such as resolving incidents
monitoring applications and
infrastructure
generating reports all these are the
actions which happens as part of
deliver and support now improve every
services
every service components every processes
every individuals
has to be improved so the focus on
software development and management of
cloud infrastructure and third-party
services
which happens as part of service value
chain this we can term it as an example
where you
your improvement can be focused on when
i say improve improvement
at all levels you can think of
improvement at a component level
improvement integration level
improvement at a service level
improvement at contribution to the
business level so as you go
on each of these levels it is quite
obvious that you need to measure
the performances at each of these levels
so as you
measure the performances at each of
these level it provides you certain
insight
is the performance is according to what
is required
what is planned or is the services is
there a deviation from the required
performance in either of these scenarios
it is very essential to
check and see if there is any
opportunity for improvement
if things are if things are going as
planned
then it's okay so you need to identify
the opportunities to improve further
from that
level that would become baseline if
things are not happening the way it is
planned
obviously that corrections are required
again the improvement thought comes in
so every services at any given point in
time one has to keep seeking
the opportunities for improvement and
keep improving that comes through
feedback what you get on a continual
basis from the consumers and users
next component is practices so there are
around 34 practices
management practices which are designed
to accomplish the specific
objectives of a services now when i say
34 practices
earlier we used to have called processes
which we used to say
process and functions in itl v3
framework so
itl v3 had defined 26 processes and then
five life cycle stages and also four
functions
now here in itl4 realizing that not a
specific process is dedicated or
associated with only one life cycle
stage each of those processes
has so much of complexity it cannot just
call as a process
and it has to be called as a practice
because of the complexity and
transactions involved for example if i
take
incident management we used to call it
as a process and we need to use to look
at that as a process
as part of service operation now
incident management process as part of
service operation
fine but what are the amount of
activities it involves what is the
complexity of
it it is it goes across the various
different functions so looking at this
scenario where this process goes across
various functions to get a result
now you think of a scenario where i need
to resolve incident by
doing certain changes now i trigger a
change management now
if you look at the entire framework of
itil v3 change management is actually
defined in
service transition lifecycle stage now
but in operations you have incident
management whereas change management is
in transition
so is that service moving back to the
previous lifecycle stage
that was the confusion so instead of
that if you say there is an incident
management
practice which is applicable
irrespective of the stage of that
particular service
change control which is applicable
across
the life cycle irrespective of the
scenario the service services is into
so then you are not bound to any
specific life cycle stage
so while incident occurs right away go
and uh take the help of
change control and then implement the
required changes and then
close the incidents so this does not
have any specific attachment
or tying between a specific stage of the
service life cycle
so if you can able to recall and
visualize vitel v3 defined about
five life cycle stages first stage was
service strategy having five processes
service design having eight processes
service transition having seven
processes
service operation having five processes
and continual service improvement having
around
one process aligned with csi model
continual service improvement model
each of this process like sla service
level agreement
which you which is there in service
design stage so this is discussed in
strategy as well
and this service levels has to be
monitored and managed
during the service operations and
services has to be
created and transitioned aligning with
the service levels defined
in design so this is what the thought
was but the existence of that service
level sla
service process what we used to call was
there universally across the life cycle
initially to define next to transition
next to monitor and manage
so it was there so the process gets
triggered some point in time but it is
there
throughout now in it four this
particular practice is not bound to a
specific life cycle stage so whenever it
is required it is triggered and each of
these practices
are interconnected certainly if i take
another example
uh like information security management
so this is also important throughout the
lifecycle
and very interesting part here is
information security management
practice is the one which is not just
for a service
provided by service provider alone the
practice of information security should
be
practiced across the organization
service providers organization
so that better information security can
be provided to
all the services provided by a service
provider so keeping this in mind
the 34 practices are grouped into three
major categories
general management practice service
management practice
and technical management practices when
i say general management practice
so these general management practices
which are around 14 practices
are applicable across the organization
right the general management practices
are applicable
across the organization and this
is not bound to any specific services
for example
change transformation right so if you
have a major change which used to call
in uh itil v3
so that requires certain amount of time
to move the organization
thought the culture everything towards
certain uh
level so that the change can become
successful across the organization
similarly information security
management which i just mentioned
so many practices which are not just
associated with one service can be
generally applicable across the
organization
so 14 general management practices are
defined so similarly
that 14 general management practices
includes information security management
relationship management strategic
management portfolio management and as a
portfolio it is a portfolio of the
organization
not just about one service so
architecture management and enterprise
architecture what we're speaking about
and service financial management
overall for all the services workforce
and talent management
continual improvement continual
improvement of all the services
to suit the business requirement to
align and complement to the business
measurement and reporting as a whole
risk management
knowledge management organizational
change management which i just mentioned
and explained
in terms of having organizational
transformation project management
supplier management so when i say
information security management to
reiterate on
so this has to focus on ensuring the
safeguarding confidentiality
integrity and availability of
information and information asset of
organization so only then all that
activities i do as part of this
organization
will be under the umbrella of
information security focus
so all that i do in this organization so
i need to ensure the information
security is taken
care of people moving from entry gate to
my data center
so can i define that as part of for data
center services
no i have a data center facility but
someone entering the premises
everyone who comes into my premises need
not go to data center but they move
around the data center it's quite
obvious and
to safeguard someone should not tailgate
without anybody's knowledge i need to
set the controls at organization level
so people who are not authorized will
not move towards data center
so the next level of security enablement
can happen
exclusively for data center so that is
again that is aligned with
the framework of information security
for the organization so it is very
essential to
consider this practice at the
organization level rather than
just at a service level the moment i
focus at organization level
so all the applicable services will also
get initiated and implemented
implementation of that particular
practice that's application of that
particular
service as well similarly if you look at
relationship management so when i say
relationship
at the broader perspective relationship
happens with two
entities two organizations two
individuals two
to organization two enterprises so it is
of that size
it's not about one individual
relationship with another individual a
service manager has a relationship with
another manager it is not that it's
about two entities service provider
organization
and customer organization consumers
organization there should be
relationship
and this relationship management also
you can look at in terms of having
across the organization within
the various different departments and
function within organization similarly
relationship between the manager and
subordinate
relationship between colleagues relation
between suppliers and service providers
relationship between service provider
and customers so it's across
so main purpose of this is to ensure a
good relationship is maintained
between organizations and its
stakeholders only then that required
collaboration and transactions can
happen
to make the business successful so
keeping in this mind rest
all the practices as i mentioned
strategic management or portfolio
management
architecture management service
financial management workforce and
talent management
continual improvement measurement and
reporting risk management
knowledge management organizational
change management
project management supplier management
all these has to considered
across the organization perspective
organization as a whole they should look
at
right so only then the required practice
of making people to understand about the
dynamics of the services dynamics of the
business can be enabled i'll take one
week example like
you have a we took the example of
restaurant earlier now if i speak about
relationship management
relating to that restaurant now who has
to maintain the relationship
now the waiter who goes and speaks to
the customer consumers who are comes to
the restaurant there should be a
relationship established if not a
relationship which
lasts for long on one-on-one basis it's
about creation of that experience
because that is one of the touch points
now that is one experience what that
consumer will have
the moment the consumer enters the
restaurant the ambiance of the
restaurant the people who take care of
the ambience of the
restaurant if they get the right
feedback in time what kind of ambience
would help what is the feedback about
this from the customer there is a
transaction and relationship which is
happening
similar the billing team the people
working in the kitchen
versus the waiter the time they manage
the information flow from them to the
waiter and then to the consumers
so all a taste of the food is that
customers enjoying the food feedback
going back to the kitchen
and making necessary corrections there
and fitting the need of the customers
and consumers on a regular basis so
understanding this relationship across
so that it's quite obvious the consumer
of a service will have a better
experience
and this is a it's not a one-time job it
should be
there always and should continue
throughout it is very essential to
demonstrate this only then customer will
have a better experience so likewise all
these
general practices generic practices
should be applicable across the
organization and demonstrated
so that you can create a better service
experience to the consumers so next is
service management practices so service
management practices
are the one which is applicable to
specific services
which are used for development
deployment delivery and support
in the organization's environment when
is organization it may be organization
of service provider organization of
consumer
organization of supplier so this
involves around
17 practices that is it asset management
monitor and event management means
monitoring each of the service
components on the service performance
business analysis service catalog
management of all the operational
services
service design service level management
for the specific service
availability management capacity and
performance management service
continuity management
service desk now remember service desk
was called
as function when we were studying idle
v3 but realizing service desk itself is
a practice
where all the four dimensions is
applicable so service desk is also
termed as
practice and there is no word called
function used in itel4 so incident
management service request management so
request fulfillment was the terminology
user
here it is real service request
management problem management
release management service validation
and testing service configuration
management
change control the seven service
management practices
now looking at one of these practices
like it asset management so
we need to understand what is itself so
all those assets
like server a database an application
an individual so each of these forms
services it we cannot we can also call
it as configuration items so one has to
manage those so so that they are
valuable asset
are realized managed properly and they
are performing
and delivering at the level which is
required to
accomplish that required performance for
creating a better service value to the
consumers of the services so it assets
are managed throughout the life cycle of
that particular idea set
and it is very essential to keep those
its performance at that level
so that no t assets which are not
considered
are not kept without the visibility
of those asset in the id service
management so that they are performing
at certain level
ensuring the services will be performing
better and that better service
performance
would result in better complement or
contribution to the
business similarly if i look at
monitoring and event management now i am
monitoring the services
performance of the service components
and then their behaviors
the capacity to list the availability of
those so i'm
monitoring those and learning the
behavior of those service components
sea ice so emphasizing on generating
and detecting the status of i.t services
its cis
throughout the life cycle of the service
so that this will keep me
clear providing that better picture so
that i will have a
clarity in terms of what needs to be
addressed at what point in time so
today's monitoring
and event management tools if i speak
about is so capable
compared with the way it was there like
15 20 years back it's so capable today
we're speaking about bringing automation
to it already lot of
tools are automated that way which
provides predictive analysis
which would provide the required action
to improve the experience of the
services
so that is the capability what we are
speaking today so focusing on this
monitoring and event management
need of a specific service what needs to
be looked at
something which is non-acceptable
behavior what is that we can term it as
something which is
okay this is how the behavior should be
that needs to be understood correctly
and then whenever the deviation occurs
monitoring and event management would
throw an alert at the same time it will
also
keep analyzing the trend of it and
providing necessary insight towards what
actions needs to be taken so
likewise each of these practices
specific to each of the services has to
be looked at
carefully and demonstrated so while
doing this one should not
ignore the fact that alignment to those
seven principles defined it is very
essential
so next is technical management
practices so when we say technical
management practices
it refers to the management of
technology domains
for the service management purposes by
expanding
or shifting their focus from technology
solutions to id services so if i am just
looking at a server
for example an application for example
as an individual component
so i am not seeing entire service as a
whole but however my focus being on that
individual id component
is also essential i cannot ignore that
part so the technology technical
management practices
are of three types which includes
deployment management
software development and management
infrastructure and platform management
so overall
general management practices 14 service
management practices 17
and technical management practices 3 so
totally 34
management practices defined in itl4 so
when i said deployment management
now as you design and transition obtain
and build
to deliver you need to deploy now while
deploying that deployment has to be
scheduled like release scheduling we do
so once that is scheduled then
deployment would happen at certain point
in time
so deployment practice would help in
terms of designing and managing and
controlling the build test
and deployment of releases in order to
deliver new functionality required by
the business
and this is for a specific service or
something which needs to be transitioned
or implemented
as part of the service life cycle where
you need a specific
technical or technological actions right
that are defined very clearly
and those needs to be complied with
similarly if you speak about
software development and management it
would focus on enhancing the quality of
software
development and ensures to provide the
required functionality for it services
so specific practice depending on the
kind of platforms which are used
similarly for infrastructure
and platform management a question may
arise here we are speaking about the
practices which are
general which are service specific which
are technically
but what about the people now people is
also a resource as the overall practices
what we have
all these are done by people so one has
to look at having enhancing the
capabilities of the individuals
which are required to demonstrate all of
these activities
that is definitely one important focus
which specifically it may not mention
but it is very essential to have those
individuals so various roles where it
can comes across like service manager
process on our service owner which we
used to
see as a designation and also roles of
service management those individuals
those roles needs to have a specific
required competencies and capabilities
only then they can perform here as part
of these practices
so next component for service value
system is continual improvement
so as we say continual improvement it's
for entire service value system
which ensures that it services
continuously
aligned to stakeholders expectations so
we just don't speak about fulfilling the
expectation of stakeholders going beyond
that expectation it's very important so
meaning giving better service experience
so the support continually improvement
at all levels
itl service value system includes
continual
improvement model which has continual
improvement practice
and uh the improved service value chain
activity
right so when i say the itl current
continual improvement model
this would provide a structured approach
to the organization
in order to bring the required
improvements on regular basis and the
word used is continual not continuous
so continual in the sense we take that
approach of pdca we plan
do check and act and that continues pdc
then improve service valuation
activities that is to establish
continual improvement into service value
chain
right so we saw that improve and service
value chain as well if
the down one in the service value chain
picture then continual improvement
practice
which supports organization in the
day-to-day improvement
efforts so this happens aligning to the
csi model which is redefined compared
with the model what was defined in the
previous version of itl
so that is having seven steps like what
is the vision being the first question
where are we now at what stage are we
now where are we now
then where do we want it to be how do we
achieve our goal how do we get there
then once you have a plan to get there
take action to get there
then did we achieve our goal did we get
there
then keep keep the momentum going by
having that feedback
so this particular csa model for
continual improvement is
aligned and followed for example if i
say what is the vision of organization
to become a best
service provider in the region where we
are doing the business if this is the
vision then are we the best service
provider at this point in time you're
answering that questions where are we
now
at what stage are we now where are we
now so you're answering no we are not
the best
we are in the third position so then uh
next immediate action
what will you take where do you want it
to be so mostly you take an action in
terms of
identification of those gaps which needs
to be addressed identification of those
opportunities which needs to be taken
care of
so that you can move ahead in terms of
reaching that position so next position
will be at least
reaching near to second one or becoming
second one would be the target
then how do we achieve that how do you
achieve that goal how do we move forward
you set up a plan for it you draft a
clear plan
and then take action do it then you
check
did we achieve our goal did we get there
so if you are there
excellent if you are not there work on
it again based on that feedback
again work based on the vision if you
achieved set up a next target
if you're not achieved check out what is
that we did not do let us continue to do
that so that we will achieve that goal
so this csa model
was depicted and followed in itel4
framework this is the one which is
actually mentioned in title four okay so
next we will look at
understanding the certification various
different certifications level defined
in
itl 4. so now itl 4 foundation
certification is an entry level
certification
which offers basic knowledge of ideal
key elements
core concepts and terminologies used in
itel4
the various levels of certifications as
defined in itl4 certification scheme
is like itl foundation is the basic
level of certification
there are three types of modules in itl
specialist
certification and two modules in itl
strategies
modules so create deliver support drive
stakeholder value high velocity id are
the three itl specialist
modules whereas direct plan and improve
digital and id strategy are the two
strategies
modules so to accomplish itl managing
professional one has to complete
these four modules so each of these
modules
create deliverance support drive
stakeholder value high velocity id
direct plan and improve are a separate
examination similar to accomplish
the certification of itl strategic
leader one has to complete
sorry direct plan and improve and
digital and id strategy certifications
so once this is complete the next level
is
itl master certification so itl 4
foundation examination format would look
like this the duration of the
examination is 1r
so totally there are 40 multiple choice
questions so each
right answers would carry one marks and
the duration of examination
is like 60 minutes so one has to score
26 that is 65 percent for 40 questions
given
and there is no negative marking for
wrong answers so once you complete the
foundation
certification one can move forward
towards accomplishing the next level of
certification i will redo this slide
from this slide
the companies using itr practices let us
look at few of the
examples so first example for us would
be the case of
disney so why disney is using iti
so it is one of the famous companies
that has adopted itr
so some of the reasons why disney is
using
and what are those issues it had earlier
so disney had
was facing the issues to maintain up to
date and accurate information
on their applications similarly the
company's management system
had difficulty in identifying the right
costumes for their cast members
and scheduled swaps where necessary it
was a challenge to maintain the
availability of assets for the customers
so adoption of itil in disney has
improved
service delivery and performance 100
availability of assets
improved reliability maintainability and
scalability of i.t services
then increase in customer engagement so
similarly there are many organizations
similar to disney as adopted itil
and has seen that value realization
happening to them
so some more organizations similar to a
disney's example what we saw would be
datacom systemsync
muller metso irs and list goes on you
name the big names in the industry
they have itl practiced actively in
their organization let us have a look at
how
you can become itl certified so itl
foundation is the first certification
so this certification is an introduction
to itl4
and helps candidates to look at it
service management
with the help of end-to-end operating
model to ease the creation
delivery and continual improvement of
tick-enabled products
further after foundation one can become
itl for managing professional
itil for strategic leader and itl
masters
to become itl for managing professionals
one has to complete
four intermediate modules defined in
itl4 whereas there is
also an opportunity for the people who
has
17 credits in itl v3 they can go for
itl managing professional transition
program and become itl 4 managing
professional to become strategic leader
itl 4 has two certifications to look at
based on that a strategic leader
certification will be provided so
managing professional
certification provides practical as well
as the technical understanding of
it-enabled services teams and workflows
it is aimed at it practitioners who work
with technology
and digital teams strategic leader this
certification helps individuals
recognize the value of itl for all
digital enabled services
it helps demonstrate how clearly one
should understand
how it influences and directs business
strategy
itl master certification is for those
individuals who need to explain and
justify
how they personally selected and applied
knowledge
principles methods and techniques from
itl and support management techniques
to ensure business objectives are
achieved so now let us
talk about popular iti job roles there
are huge number of itl job roles let us
have a look at some of
the most popular ones so incident
manager
problem manager change manager business
relationship manager
project manager service level manager
change manager
so the responsibilities of change
manager includes
controlling the life cycle of all
changes change manager
should enable beneficial changes to be
made with minimal disruption to the i.t
services
for more important changes the change
manager should consult the change
advisory board
for authorization problem manager so
responsibility of problem manager
includes
problem manager is responsible for
managing the lifecycle of all problems
problem managers should ensure
prevention of incidents from taking
place
and to minimize their impact if they
cannot be prevented for this
problem manager should be well-versed
with the known errors and workarounds
incident manager the responsibilities of
incident manager includes
the incident manager is responsible for
implementation of the incident
management process and reporting
incident manager is the first stage of
escalation of incidents in the
situations
where they are not resolved within the
agreeable service levels
business relationship manager the
responsibilities of business
relationship manager
is to maintain a positive relationship
with customers
and to identify customer needs and
making sure
these needs are satisfied a business
relationship manager
works closely with service level
managers project
manager the responsibilities of project
manager includes
planning and coordinating resources to
deploy
a major release within the predicted
cost time and quality
service level manager the responsibility
of service level
manager includes responsible for
negotiating and ensuring service level
agreements are met
a service level manager should make sure
that it service management processes
operational agreements
and underpinning contracts are
appropriate for the required service
level targets
so a service level manager should
monitor and report on service levels
on regular basis hope it was informative
and interesting
if you have any questions regarding the
itil topics covered in this particular
video
please ask away in the comment section
below and our team of experts will be
happy to solve all your queries
thank you for watching stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here